here's the thing neither one of them are
great boxers so at this level to bet on
the dogs is not a terrible idea to bet
on a guy in Dylan danis who's plus 330
who has legit martial arts background
not terrible I think no matter if you
take Logan or Dylan it won't matter
because Dylan's gonna do something crazy
and it's gonna throw all this out the
window that's my prediction is Dylan
isn't having success on the feet is just
like F this and chokes them out or at
least attempts to and security jumps in
they stop the fight that's what I think
happens then you have KSI Tommy Fury
who's not being talked about at all
which is crazy because of who D I don't
see in any facet how KSI wins that fight
his build up for this has been atrocious
him doing this weird like WWE like I'm
gonna my soul I will die
what what